on passe à des sujets de la semaine
c'est le zapping de la semaine ça j'aime
beaucoup le début de la semaine parce
qu'il ya du zap pasquet du ping et on a
des fois vous savez c'est un dur métier
de finalisation oui donc interdite on a
trouvé les pires parents du monde
ils sont très très à cheval sur leur
travail et quand on appelle parce que la
petite un problème ben y'a le fromage
qui cuit le lait doit être brassée
pendant 40 minutes à 33 degrés sorti
trop tôt
le fromage ne prendra pas au moindre
imprévu
tout est perdu chercher
à moins que marie soit vraiment mourante
va falloir fait patienter un petit peu
on perd pas est alors on ne rigole pas
avec l'atome c'est clair que c'est
n'importe quoi c'est pas une émission
sur elle aussi sur les français et leur
comportement sexuel way we en troisième
partie de soirée c'était des moments
assez assez basses et sexuelle à ses
principes et là il ya un jeune homme qui
inquiète encore puceau visiblement
l'activité sexuelle c'est un truc qu'il
n'a pas envisagé c'est un fait
accessoire voilà c'est donc si ça arrive
tant mieux ça arrive pas tant pis
combien avez vous de rapports sexuels
par mois ah bah là moi c'est même en
dessous de moi c'est moi un ennemi oui -
0 pour faire me taper un bon plateau
repas devant une bonne série que
masturber coiffe 0 pourquoi parce que
j'attende la personne idéale
à chaque fois il ya eu ni les jeunes
femmes que je rencontrais c'était plutôt
on reste pote avec toi il ya même des
choses je me dis voilà pour moi le sexe
dans un complot ne s'est pas forcément
obligatoire quoi mais mais j'aimerais
quand même essayer quoi aller jusqu'au
bout
[Applaudissements]
daniel moreau il est chaud est la
spécialiste pour l'expliquer mais bon
c'est juste un peu les séances de tests
et une bonne série dallas sur le canapé
pourquoi pas s'il voit le décours la
annonce alors ça se passe dans un camion
venait à mon avis il avait dû se dire on
va diffuser d'émissions vert vers 22h30
les images mettent à 00h30
c'est extrêmement extrêmement voilà
alors un zapping sans génie du pape ne
serait pas un hasard ping sent-il
compilé encore eu des bons mots de
français visiblement langue française à
eux
ça fait deux n'est ce pas magali dit
mercury on sent la complicité chat une
vraie relation se serait sûre et neil
changé au fraternelle comme un petit
pont des soeurs fusionnelle et sans
nuage sera donné sur un corner sam
je vous sont totalement admiratif c'est
les gens très inspire hâtif alors ce
style tu nous comme vous pouvez le voir
donc elle tournait les rangs du lait de
manger des réflexions comme ça ça vous
espère
quand le chat n'est pas là
des cacahuètes dedans ça fera et on nous
l'a promis semaine prochaine normalement
on aura les génies du pas venir réduits
à nous aussi parce qu on a quand même
quelques formules sur la vie des
candidats avec nous pour moi c'est
pareil c'est un cauchemar dans 66 le
pire c'est qu'ils se foutrait de ma
gueule dans 66 minutes diffusé sur la
voyance et le salon de la voyance
ah ouais là il ya un voyant si vous
allez le voir et que vous n'êtes pas
très bien prévoyez une corde un couteau
quelque chose que pour finir voilà signe
à 46 ans elle veut se rassurer sur sa
vie sentimentale lapassade ans entre les
deux et elle va être servi d'après
michael elle va rompre avec franck le
père de sa fille celui-là 120 et le
prochain que vous emmènera avec vous
vous risquez de partir avec celui là
dans le midi vous risquer ainsi de
continuer à l'étranger et vous le
quitterez pour un autre là bas la
vieille visart
les hommes c'est comme des valises et
oui j'aimerais ça m'incite à la grève
est cuit vous vous avez envie que ça
dure
nous avons envie d'aller plus loin lui
non il est très attiré par vous mais
c'est une question de physique question
charnelle c'est une question sexuelle on
peut le dire aussi persuadé qu'il nous
reste 23 ans on m'a prédit sur ce
plateau que j'allais me péter la jambe
à l'arrivée un mois dans les geôles
terrorisés pour l'histoire du voyant
mais en plus ce n'est plus jamais les
voir en plus qu'en fait je fais des
économies allaient quand même avec moi
non mais bon parfois ils disent pas des
conneries la preuve je suis cassé la
jambe maintenant dans quel exclusive et
il y avait justement une enquête sur le
trafic de permis et là c'était
franchement sa fin ça faisait peur il
faut savoir qu'on peut effectivement
acheté son permis ce n'est qu'une
question de prix moi j'ai besoin je peux
aller jusqu'à 1500 ces engins de taille
faire traîner c'est à moi je pense que
c'est donc là comment ça marche et
repart pour vous
d'accord que si je passe d'exploser de
trois fautes oui
logique ça fait longtemps qu'on en
entend parler mais c'était comme juste
scandaleux parce que avoir une voiture
une voiture ceci une arme n'a pas
l'oublier que chaque année il ya des
millions de personnes qui décèdent dans
des accidents de la turquie se renverser
ce genre de personne pour mais tout
aussi responsables que les propres
conducteurs dont je suis désolé mais là
c'est criminel alors on a appris
d'ailleurs le nom dans l'émission que y
est donc allé jusqu'en côte d'ivoire
pour passer leur permis de conduire
parce que là-bas alors ici c'est assez
difficile en côte d'ivoire c'est
beaucoup plus simple regardez on
commence par l'examen du code de la
route
les panneaux et les règles sont
identiques aux nôtres
mais le manuel est presque cinq fois
plus légers qu'en france
chaque candidat passe individuellement
devant un examinateur et tout se fait à
l'oral quels sont les malheureux pour le
doit pas faire un virage en conduite
s'arrêter ou montre le panneau
stationnement interdit
c'est bon manteau - le panneau sens
interdit
ok l'épreuve dure 6 minutes chrono
t'habiller voilà votre résultat il ya eu
plusieurs d'escroquerie aux familles de
conduire qui ont été des banques les
révéler au grand public et qui touchait
notamment deux des personnalités
ah oui dont on ne parlera pas maintenant
on attend d elle aime bien surtout pas
on a déjà assez dormir comme la série
l'édition sne a aussi fait la
connaissance de fanta qui n'est pas une
boisson mais une conductrice qui bat
allées sont permis mais ça se voit pas
beaucoup en fait c'est tout à fait
honnête
fanta à 19 ans elle a eu son permis il y
a deux jours
[Musique]
fanta n'a pas encore quitté le
stationnement qu'elle provoque son
premier incident de jeunes conductrices
manque de chance son frère fait ce qu'il
peut pour éviter l'accident
mais il ne peut empêcher un premier
accrochage heureusement ce n'est que le
rétroviseur va se faire la main oui mais
alors il a même c'est pas une vraie
voiture d'auto-école
ils ont permis mais pas couché avec
chalencon et marc lavoine la drague elle
alors c'était pas accepter c'était très
gênant parce que chalencon il était très
sûr marc lavoine et marc lavoine était
très pas sur chalon joue en fait dans
mes chansons il est très sûr tout le
monde me regarde et eric et physique
c'est comme si on va aux invalides où on
ouvre moi j'adore faire comment vous
faites la mecque de pierre-jean
chalencon quoi oui voilà c'est ma mec
m'a mec à moi c'est pas mal mais comment
j'ai fait je vais arrêter de touché il
est trés ça va être vous avez vous avez
habité rue de rivoli moi aussi un moment
oui c'est comme ça que vous draguez
chalencon moi j'essaye quoi
[Rires]
la cci a une petite lourdeur quand même
les auteurs et une gênante
oui mais il est sympa marque il est très
bon dirigeant comme ça un mot est venu
ici et c'était très la volaille les
sympathies un personnage d'abby la belle
bague en plus donc ça va les gars nadal
mais voilà qu'on pense qu'à l'héritage
où il a des grosses bagues battant
salaire ils valent une fortune ces bacs
julia pour plusieurs millions à dents
sur que sur les doigts
il exhibe errants elle est sympa et très
sympathique merci beaucoup alors on veut
réduire sur enquêtes paranormales qui a
fait un carton cette semaine sur ses
huit plus de 6 613 me les spectateurs
les ris avec une autre notre ami notre
amour on adore tous ces veilles benhaim
et à ces déconvenues
il compile des lancements alors soit
vous êtes vraiment en panique soit il ya
des mots que à comprendra pas bien c'est
paranormal les deux hommes sont
retrouvés morts au sommet d'une colline
avec posés sur leurs visages d'étranges
masque de plomb il s'appelle maurice
thériault cet américain d'origine
française et est possédé par le diable
et les images sont terrifiantes une
immense créatures ailées mi homme mi
papillon appelé le mosman alors faut-il
croire cet homme qui prévoyait l'avenir
grâce à des rituels de magie
la découverte sur l'île de porto rico de
centaines de cadavres d'animaux mutilés
et vidés de leur sang allait donner
naissance à l'une des plus terrifiantes
légende celle du chou paca bras
[Applaudissements]
tout elle va je trouve qu'elle est
talentueuse et qu elle est talentueuse
pardon et elle s'en sort super bien
qu'elle soit animatrice danser que de la
télé elle est exceptionnelle que ce soit
chroniqueuse en tp mpl exceptionnelle et
qu'elle soit d'animatrice dans cette
émission qui est une émission assez
particulière pour pouvoir parler comme
ça faut avoir un talent fausses et c'est
fort c'est être animatrice en juin et on
en croit ce qui au passage a exclu cette
invite avec cette ce sujet sur le
festival de dunkerque
bah oui ils savent bien s'amuser un il
savait s'amuser et puis là il a une puce
unités on va vous regarder ce père de
famille travaillent à l'usiné mise en
place le jour
alors il se délecte de créer chaque
année avec un ami pâtissier une petite
merveille gustatives quand je suis la
première fois devoir pour le le sinn ma
tante dans mon prototype le zizi était
du fako lundi dur c'était un moulage
plein vous est donc si vrai que pour
croquer si tu croques le zizi dur sur
une meringue la vague se casse
[Applaudissements]
vous fait toujours rire appelle les
coucougnettes aussi c'est superbe
voilà vous allez souvent qu au carnaval
de nice ça va vous vous êtes très bien
alors justement l'art dans ce carnaval
de dunkerque il ya aussi une tradition
ce sont les chansons paillardes
voilà alors regardez les parce qu'ils
chantent aussi c'est ses traites et
forme ses traits cette invite à regarder
écouter des chants irrévérencieux
et
les plus explicites possible
[Musique]
oui j'en ai ça
une célébration de tous les excès pour
l'alcool coule à flots même si la charte
du carnaval et ferme les personnes ivres
morts qui ne sont pas les biens et
minutes enquête on aime un sujet sur la
police belge et on en a passé un boucher
série ne serait que tout montre n'a
parlé c'est ce policier qu'il veut faire
un plaquage sur un malfrat est bas il va
pas plaquer malfrats mais en revanche le
mur va bien le voir de près
dans sa tentative de plaquage
un policier se cogne violemment contre
un mur
[Applaudissements]